[Música]
yo que un momento hablar de la revista
de prensa aquí en directo américa ya
está lista en el estudio rosa pérez más
de eeuu para hablar del recorrido por
las portadas de todos los periódicos de
los medios de comunicación de francia
pues no todos pero sí en los más
importantes vamos a ver como titulan la
victoria de macrón le figaro libre de
liberación lemont y también mediapart y
para ello nuevamente nos acompaña aquí
reza pared más de euros a bienvenida
nuevamente hola de nuevo raúl pues
empecemos por los figaro es que me dio
abiertamente de derechas que dice que a
pesar de todo es una victoria histórica
de macrón sobre el open por otro lado
liberación se plantea gracias a quien no
macro no fue reelegido y dice que macrón
debe su victoria a los franceses que se
movilizaron ampliamente para frenar pues
a una extrema derecha más fuerte que
nunca en un sobresalto democrático y de
hecho destacar que ayer macrón reconoció
por primera vez a los franceses que le
votaron no porque apoyaran sus ideas
sino para hacer frente a la llegada del
epen al elíseo por otro lado lo montan
bien en relación a la extrema derecha y
a su situación tras estas elecciones
dice que está a un nivel histórico pero
nos fijamos en los resultados
definitivos que destaca el lo mont y que
pues señala esta alta abstención pero
queríamos resaltar raúl que más personas
de hecho se abstuvieron fueron 13
millones 60 13 millones 650 mil personas
las que optaron por la abstención frente
a 13 millones 300 mil que votaron por
lope no por lo tanto más personas se
abstuvieron que no apoyaron a la extrema
derecha eso es también destacable por
otro lado mediapart dice lópez al alza y
macro vencedor por caos y se pregunta a
mediapart si la izquierda va a lograr
resucitar declaradas legislativas no un
poco lo que comentábamos y este llamado
de jean-luc miran son el líder de la
francia insumisa pues a ser la fuerza
más votada en la asamblea nacional y así
poder ser elegido el primer ministro que
macro dónde va a elegir lo primero del
nuevo gobierno bueno así las cosas las
portadas nacionales pero como titula a
la prensa internacional la victoria de
macro en rosa pues empezamos por europa
porque uno de los ejes principales de
macrón de su campaña y de su mandato es
este pues
ajeno europeísta y precisamente en
francia dan mucha importancia a este eje
franco-alemán por esto destacamos el
frankfurter allgemeine que dice alivio
en europa tras la reelección de macrón y
recordemos que ayer en su de camino a su
discurso de victoria en esa escena
rodeado de niños y de la mano de su
mujer sonaba el himno de europa de fondo
no raúl por otro lado en el mismo
sentido la repubblica de italia dice con
macrón gana europa del 'times' del reino
unido dice macrón promete reunir francia
tras su victoria electoral un poco en
sentido en el sentido de esas fracturas
no que hablábamos antes aquí en el
continente americano clarín de argentina
dice que macro no logró frenar a la
ultraderecha y hay alivio en europa
alivio esta palabra que se repite en los
titulares para definir la situación tras
esta segunda vuelta el wall street
journal
macrón vence al epen y gana un nuevo
mandato presidencial hasta 2027
recordemos y el 'global times' de china
destaca que la obsesión de los medios
occidentales con estas elecciones
refleja pues la ansiedad que sentía
occidente pues por si se mantenía una
relación de francia con la unión europea
y con eeuu y sobre todo el papel de
francia en esta guerra en ucra rosa pero
nos hemos querido detener en un gráfico
que publica el diario le monde como lo
comentábamos anteriormente comparando
los resultados de las presidenciales
pasadas de la quinta república así es y
hemos querido fijarnos particularmente
en las segundas vueltas donde ha llegado
la extrema derecha al poder y si bien ha
ido en aumento la abstención desde 2002
cuando jacques chirac se enfrentó al
padre del marine lepén jean-marie le pen
también ha ido en aumento el apoyo a la
extrema derecha y es que si bien el jean
marie le pen en 2002 obtenía el 18 por
ciento de los apoyos que se traducía en
5,5 millones de votantes ahora mismo
obtuvo 44 45% de los votos lo que se
traduce en términos absolutos en más de
13 millones pues de sufragios a su favor
no la bola desea más que duplicado en 20
años el apoyo a la extrema derecha en
esta segunda vuelta y también hemos
querido detenernos en el mapa de
mediapart con una repartición del
territorio en los votos no rosa
exactamente y hermosa he querido de
hecho media parte hace una comparativa
entre lo que es pues la distribución
territorial de los votos en la primera y
en la segunda vuelta pero nos hemos ha
querido fijar particularmente en el
ultramar francés en guadalupe la reunión
guayana martinica y es que en todos
estos territorios de hecho marín lópez
ganó ampliamente en esta segunda vuelta
y este es un caso bien particular porque
en estos territorios fue jean-luc
mélenchon quien encabezó la primera
vuelta sin embargo esto es destacable
porque según los sondeos de ipsos es el
42 por ciento de los votantes de
jean-luc mélenchon en la primera vuelta
han apoyado a macrón en la segunda no
sólo un 17% ha apoyado al epp en ciento
frente a un 41% que ha votado en blanco
nulo o se abstuvo rápidamente seremos
con dos caricaturas rosa eso es coco en
liberación muestra una imagen del peón
pateando a sus gatos desenmascarando se
podemos decir un poco de esta imagen
afable que ha mostrado pues para hacer
campaña y por otro lado surge en la
radio de cine pues se muestra a macrón
con un coche de policía preguntando qué
programa y dice para saberlo abramos un
poco la caja de pandora no y es que una
de las críticas a su mandato precedente
ha sido esta violencia policial que
recordemos ayer ya se repitió contra
esta manifestación en plaza de la
república pues vamos a ver cómo continúa
a lo largo de estos cinco años y cuál es
finalmente promesas se acaban
materializando de manuel maca y qué va a
pasar en junio que las legislativas
rosas muchísimas gracias por toda esta
revista de prensa mañana con más pasamos
a los deportes